[Música]
cuántos de ustedes han escuchado una
historia como esta hacen la tarea
separan el plástico el vidrio el
aluminio la hojalata el papel el cartón
todo en bolsitas separado los sacan el
día que corresponde porque ese día pasa
el camión del reciclaje pero no pasó
pasó el camión regular
y el camión de la basura tomo todo este
esfuerzo y lo revolvió con el resto de
la basura a cuánto les ha pasado eso
otras razones muy comunes son aquellas
que en mi comunidad solamente tenemos
campaña de reciclaje una vez al mes
entonces ya empiezo a guardar mis
residuos
en el cuarto de pilas
ya no me caben los paso al garaje a la
cochera ya no me cabe también metió un
poquito en el carro hasta que la esposa
o el esposo harto le dice no te llevas
esos chinches o te los voto mañana a
quien le ha pasado
esta es la realidad con la que nosotros
vivimos
en el país según los datos del
ministerio de salud generamos 4000
toneladas de residuos al día un kilo por
persona más o menos
y saben qué pasa con estos residuos
el 87% se va a un relleno sanitario
todos los días
el 7% no tiene un mejor destino queda
por ahí en la naturaleza y solamente un
6% es recuperado para poder convertirlo
en algo útil en el proceso de reciclaje
que se hace mayoritariamente fuera del
país aquí en costa rica se recicla menos
del 1%
porque tenemos tan malos resultados
porque vivimos en el ego sistema por un
lado el gobierno por otro la academia
por otro las empresas por otro las ongs
las municipalidades por otro y los
consumidores alejados de esta
participación esa discusión
porque todos los días
tiramos el dinero a la basura
literalmente enterramos el 87 por ciento
de los residuos en un relleno sanitario
generando además problemas sociales y de
contaminación ambiental quien quiere
acercar a su comunidad a un relleno
sanitario para que le bajen la plusvalía
a su vivienda
porque si no queremos los residuos nos
empeñamos en seguir haciendo las cosas
como desde hace 30 años con el mismo
camión que pasa por la casa
esta famosísima frase se aplica perfecto
a nuestro tema
cuáles son los sistemas que funcionan
cómo es que logramos incidir y cambiar
cuando primero facilitamos las
soluciones y segundo premiamos el
comportamiento deseado facilitamos el
camino y premiamos el comportamiento les
voy a dar dos ejemplos en las sociedades
en los que los donadores de órganos o
las donaciones de órganos son muy
exitosas es porque usted naturalmente es
donador de órganos y para no serlo tiene
que ir a un lugar y desee inscribirse de
la lista
o en sociedades donde la educación
financiera es muy importante cuando
usted va a pagar la tarjeta porque no
queremos que la gente se endeude con las
tarjetas de crédito usted encuentra un
botón grandote que dice pago de contado
y un botón chiquito que dice pago mínimo
pero que nos pasa con los bancos al
revés pago mínimo y entonces empezamos a
endeudarnos el sistema no nos ayuda
desde hace muchos años tal vez unos diez
años en mi equipo hemos estado
monitoreando este tema
y hace unos tres nos aventuramos a
generar una alternativa una herramienta
para ser parte de la solución y no solo
del problema y entonces tal vez algunos
de ustedes han visto este vídeo por ahí
que habla de que el tema del reciclaje
de la contaminación por residuos no es
un problema ambiental
lo hemos dejado convertirse en un
problema ambiental pero es una
oportunidad de negocios es una
oportunidad económica si dejamos de
enterrar el dinero todos los días según
relleno sanitario el colon es es el
nombre que le pusimos si no puede ser
mastico es el eco de nuestra marca país
de la forma en que nos hemos posicionado
internacionalmente y el colon nuestra
queridísima moneda pues de colones es un
programa de lealtad toma algunas
experiencias de la de nuestro sistema de
consumo y las convierte en un programa
de lealtad post consumo para premiar los
comportamientos deseados
a ver ayúdenme ustedes aquí a hacer este
ejercicio pero no me pueden mentir
si yo les hago esta pregunta estamos los
ticos conscientes de los problemas
ambientales urgentes hablemos de los
residuos si yo les digo aquí pónganse de
pie en este auditorio los que están
conscientes de que los problemas
ambientales son urgentes quienes se
pondrían de pie sin mentir
de pie de pie
a ver estamos conscientes
son urgentes los estudios nos dicen que
de cada 10 personas
8 por lo menos
están conscientes y bueno aquí yo creo
que el promedio anda un poquito más bajo
no sé por qué se sentaron de esos
conscientes a ver solamente siéntense
los que no están dispuestos a hacer nada
todavía se quedan de pie los que están
dispuestos a hacer algo
bueno parece que más o menos coincide
con la estadística porque dice que son
cuatro de esos ocho o sea la mitad de
los que están conscientes están
dispuestos a hacer algo y ahora solo
quédense de pie los que ya hacen algo
hoy
sinceramente nadie los va a juzgar
solo los que hacen algo hoy por estos
problemas y que desde de pie ahora los
que creen que están siendo efectivos con
lo que están haciendo que lo que están
haciendo tiene resultados tangibles
ahí está señores podemos otra vez ver
cómo el sistema no nos ayuda gracias
ahora si pueden sentarse vean solo lo
que estamos recuperando es apenas un 6%
no estamos siendo eficientes por más que
queramos hacerlo tengamos la intención
el conocimiento el sistema no nos ayuda
topamos con barreras una y otra vez
ineficiencia municipal falta de
información falta de una industria del
reciclaje y eso es bastante frustrante y
lo sabemos nos hemos topado con muchas
nos muchas barreras en este camino de la
innovación a mi jefe no le va a gustar
yo no tengo tiempo no tengo plata no me
gusta el cambio y muchas formas
diferentes de decir las estrategias
océano azul encuentran mucha resistencia
pero no importa la innovación es más
fuerte que es el programa que puede ser
llevado américa latina que tiene una
agenda ya comprometida con 12 países en
la región vamos a llevar y coins a 12
países y vamos a hacer muy fuertes con
esta innovación de costa rica- una
moneda tica que podemos compartir con el
mundo y más allá les voy a contar que me
pasó hace poco tiempo me llamo antón
un periodista danés que dijo yo quiero
aprender qué es lo que está haciendo
costa rica en gestión de residuos
o sea un periodista danés donde tienen
un porcentaje de reciclaje como del 87
por ciento bueno antón vino estuve en el
centro de acopio de montesdeoca conversó
con la gente y después yo entendí los
países más ricos son los que tienen el
mayor reto en el tema de producción y
consumo sostenible producen demasiado
consumen demasiado y generan demasiado y
residuos de tal forma que costa rica
aunque está en el lugar número 33 ojo
que estamos mejor en desarrollo
sostenible que en la fifa
tenemos una gran oportunidad vean este
gráfico los países de la ocde los más
ricos son los que están viviendo en el
objetivo de desarrollo sostenible número
12 están queda 2 están con otra roja y
nosotros estamos mejor de tal forma que
cualquier idea fabricado en costa rica
creada en costa rica generada desde la
economía circular y la innovación donde
el camión deje de ser el centro donde el
camión deje de ser el que maneja todos
los residuos donde sean los consumidores
los que pueden escoger a qué empresa que
no empresa ir pueden llevar los residuos
al lugar donde realmente los necesitamos
y pueden generar diferenciación con las
empresas que otorgan estos beneficios
por premiar los comportamientos deseados
o amorós en la economía circular que
toma poco de la naturaleza reduce
reutiliza repara rescata recicla
y vuelve otra vez el proceso de
regeneración somos redonditos es un
planeta redondo vámonos al concepto de
circularidad de regeneración es la única
manera en la que podemos seguir adelante
muchas gracias
[Música]